all right good afternoon everyone and
welcome to the webinar about revised
release plans for the NCBI API keys my
name is Eric Cirrus and I'll be guiding
you through a few minutes of updates
about this and again at the bottom there
is a link that go usa.gov URL that
provides a direct link to the materials
and ultimately to the QA alright so with
that I'm going to go ahead and get
started
one little plug I'd like to make before
we actually get into the webinar is
interact office hours today's at 2:30 so
if you would like to come and learn more
about either act or have questions
comments issues with eat erect the URL
is there this is part of an ongoing
training program that NLM is providing
for eject and edirect for those of you
don't know is a UNIX interface to the
utilities API and if you do work on the
UNIX command line this is a great tool
that you might want to check out and see
how it might be able to be useful for
you so that's at 2:30 today alright so
moving forward what we'd like to do
today is talk a little bit about some
updates to our plans for API keys we've
talked about this a couple of times in
the past and just to kind of update you
on on where we are now
so in November we did a couple of
webinars about API keys introducing the
idea of them and updating you on our
plans this is now a third installment in
that series so I'll talk to you about
what's happening at the moment what we
see happening going forward I'll do a
little quick review for those of you who
haven't attended those other webinars
and if you haven't attended those other
webinars please check them out it'll
give you some good background material
about what we're talking about today
then I'll try and catch you up in terms
of where we are a little review I'm
going to talk about a sandbox
environment that we've released that if
you're a developer should be very useful
to you as well as some upcoming testing
periods and how those are going to work
and then going ultimately to full
release of the keys so what's happening
the thing that's really happening that
we're excited about is we're
getting a lot of feedback from people
and this is exactly what we want we want
to hear from you about what's useful to
you what you're doing with the API how
we can help you do what you're doing
better how we can understand your needs
and we've had a number of good
conversations about that and we're
continuing to have conversations so
please engage us in those conversations
as we move forward because that's really
helping us understand how we can help
you as a result of that we're not
honoring our May first release date so
originally back in November we had
targeted May first which is now just you
know a few days away as the date when
API keys will be going fully live they
will not be that date is being pushed
back to no earlier than September first
so relax you've got time you've got the
summer to get ready for this and we will
let you know well in advance if that day
changes but it will not be before
September 1st 2018 when keys go fully
live what we have done is to create a
sandbox that is active today it's been
active for a little bit but it is active
now where the keys are always active and
as I'll talk about a little bit more in
a few minutes this is a good simulation
of what production will be like very
likely in the fall and we will be having
some test periods no more than about an
hour on production over the coming weeks
months where the keys will become active
and so this is a chance to test code in
the actual production environment and
also to check things that maybe we
aren't aware ever you're not aware of
that might be affected by the upcoming
keys so a quick review of what we're
talking about in terms of the API is
that are being affected so these are the
e-utilities only and again no blast
api's no other api's are being affected
by this the utilities are the entree API
so east search summary fetch link and
post these are the things you use to do
searches and pubmed or gene or
nucleotide to get a summary doc sums to
get you know fast a or abstracts or
citation formats of various kinds of our
litter
Shirin sequence data so those are the
api's that you need to be concerned
about so if you're using them then you
need to pay attention if you're using
blast api's this is not something that's
relevant at the moment what are keys so
an API key is a unique string right
that's going to be added to the URL
request that string identifies you to
the API and it needs to be included in
every API request that you make these
API keys are attached to an NCBI account
some of you may have known this in the
past as a my NCBI account but they're an
instant icon that you set up one account
can have a single API key and one of the
big reasons that we're doing this is we
want the API to be more stable and
reliable for you and having these keys
helps us make that happen by being
better able to monitor and regulate the
amount of traffic that comes in to our
services we'd love to have infinite
capacity and we don't no one does but to
make it seem as if we have capacity that
meets your needs this is a good way for
us to help regulate that and help you
regulate it to the point that it can
work for you as well as possible so how
do you get a key this is again just a
reminder you go to my NCBI or to NCBI
accounts so you need to find the link on
NCBI pages that link is in the upper
right hand corner of NCBI pages you can
sign in to NCBI you can create an
account there if you don't already have
one if you have an NCBI account you can
please use that if you'd like to create
a new account only for your software
that's fine and then there will be a
button under API key management where
you will be able to create an API key
it'll just put it on the screen you can
copy it and there you have it how do you
use the key it's very simple you assign
it to the parameter named API underscore
key so you just put that parameter in
any of your and all of your utility API
requests so I'm showing an e info and
you search one here for example you just
put API key equals and whatever the key
is if you are an indirect user as we
mentioned at the beginning of the
webinar there is an environmental
variable named NCBI underscore API
underscore key he can simply set that
environmental variable and then edirect
will automatically attach your API key
to all outgoing requests that you make
through direct if you want to get a new
key you can but your own key dies
immediately so you can only have one
keeper NCBI account so you're perfectly
happy to get rid of one if you think
it's you know someone else's got it and
you're concerned about that or whatever
reason you you're tired of it you can
get rid of it but when you replace it
the other one goes away immediately and
will no longer be active and I want to
say a word before I start talking about
rates about how we define rates because
what we're going to be talking about is
keys setting rate limits on the number
of requests coming in and so if you get
an error
all right about these rates I'm showing
that at the top of the slide you'll get
little error text back saying that the
API rate limit was exceeded and account
meaning the number of requests that we
saw in a particular second and the
important thing for people to realize is
that we're looking at a one-second
moving window and we care about when the
requests were received at NCBI not the
execution time so what we really care
about is the fact that you've started
more than your limit of requests in a
one-second window in the bottom here you
see a lot of requests that are taking a
number of seconds but there's no time
during that activity where more than
three requests are being received per
second for example if the relate limit
was three as we'll talk about that's one
of the default limits so that's how
these rates are being defined so there's
a new sandbox that we have the new
sandbox is an environment where all the
keys will be active permanently and so
this is a great place to go to test
alright and so you can hit this what's
different about this for those of you
who are familiar with the API is that
the URL is API NCBI data lentonite / e
utils so it's not WW it's not utils NCBI
but API in CIL NIH
slash utils it's not slash entre slash
utils
simply /e utils right so the keys are
always going to be active there and this
will simulate ultimate production right
so it's active now you can start testing
now the bottom of the slide I just put a
couple of example URLs there so you can
see if I want to do an e search I simply
do API dot dot the dot slash util slash
research that F CGI and whatever I'm
doing and you're off and so whatever
you're doing just change that base URL
to API NCBI slash utils so what happens
in the sandbox so if you've been at one
of our previous webinars you've heard me
say this but I'm gonna say it again just
to make sure we're all on the same page
so this is the behavior that happens now
in the sandbox and will happen when we
go live in full production so if you
don't have a key
let's start there if you don't have a
key the limit is three requests per
second for each individual IP so what
I'm showing here is three IP addresses
alright the first one has two requests
per second alright so that's fine no key
the second one has five requests per
second in a given second that will cause
an error all right so you'll get an
error when you when you get those back
and one and a half requests per second
no problem so as long as you're but note
below three requests per second for any
one second Luling window you're fine now
what happens to those requests that
receive an error they're just not
processed all right you're not blocked
there's nothing like that that's
happening once the second window passes
and you go beneath your rate limit
you'll get access again immediately all
right and the requests will start
working so what you'll see in your data
is gaps you know where you're not
getting data back you know why am I not
getting data back because you got
momentarily blocked right if I want to
say it that way
by the rate limit but keep in mind this
is not like your IP getting blocked or
anything like that it's very
instantaneous so once the rates go down
below the limit then you're live and
well again what happens if you've got at
IP that two people are shared
or multiple people are sharing so what
happens here is we have two people
sharing the same IP one of them is doing
two requests per second one of they're
doing is five both get affected right
because it's by IP all right so you have
multiple users in the same IP if you got
one actor that's over three requests per
second everyone gets affected right so
that can be a potential issue right it
for large distributed things or you have
a lot of people behind a firewall or
whatever it might be it depends on the
IP if there is no key right so that's
the important thing to remember what
happens if you have a key all right so
now I have several scenarios here where
there's a key present so in this case
the first two people there have the same
IP address but two different keys first
guy has key a B to three he's underneath
ten requests per second because with a
key the default limit goes from three to
ten so as long as you're beneath ten
requests per second with a key you're
fine so seven is cool
right and his request will go through
his friend though that's doing fifteen
requests per second we'll get errors
right different key the third guy down
there at a different IP address doesn't
matter for requests per second he has a
different key so my point here is it's
really about the key not the IP address
doesn't matter how many people share the
IP address or whether you have a
separate IP address it only matters what
key you have and how many requests are
coming in on that particular key so for
example here we have a case where we're
mixing alright so some people have a key
and some people don't have a key so what
happens everybody is on the same IP
address all right first guy has a key a
B two three it's less than ten he's fine
second guy has a different key he's at
fifteen he gets errors third guy has no
key so now what it does it to it looks
at the IP because there's no key right
in that IP address is getting 7 plus 15
which is 22 plus 2 is 24 requests per
second he gets errors right so this
hopefully illustrates to you kind of the
problems you can have if you've got a
lot of people using the same eye
so the best approach is have each person
have their own key right because then
that key to terminate it is true though
that if you have people using the same
key right then we see the some of that
right from that same key and one person
may get errors right and if they get
errors everybody using that key will get
errors all right because it's attached
to the key so that's an issue if you're
using a distributed scenario where
multiple people are going to be using
the same key if one of them gets above
the threshold then they all are affected
so to review quickly the situation is if
you don't have a key any IP address that
post more than the limit will be
affected and get errors so it's about
IPS if there's no key if there is a key
it's about the key all right so any key
that posts more than 10 or whatever the
limit is will receive errors so that's
the real bottom line if you don't have a
key it's about the IP address if you do
have a key it's about whoever's using
that key however many people that might
represent so that's what's going to be
happening in the sandbox all right so
that happens now and so you can begin
testing that now all right so if you got
code you want to test shoot it to API
two at NCBI and see what happens and
verify that everything's working the
testing periods are going to be
happening in production we don't yet
have a schedule of these but I will be
publicizing them on utilities announced
and on our social media right so if you
haven't signed up for utilities
announced please do so I'll have a link
at the end of the presentation that will
give you access to that you can sign up
or pay attention right to our Twitter
feed our blog we'll be talking about it
there and again the behavior of
production during the test period will
be identical to the sandbox now right so
this is a way of checking production
code it's also a way for us just seeing
what breaks alright and having a little
brief period where we can just make sure
that we're aware of things and that you
are aware of things that are going to be
affected by this so we will give you
warning about when these are going to be
happening so that you can plan for it
they want to be no more than an hour and
they will occur at different times
during the day
cuz people use our API is 24/7 so you
want to make sure that we hit times at
different parts of the day to make sure
that we're getting everybody's full
release so after we do a few of these
testing periods we will publicize the
date of full release and we will give
you at least three months notice as to
when that will be
right now we're saying it's not going to
be before September first it moves
further back then we'll let you know
with at least three months notice and
that means that all keys will become
active we would like to also advise you
and we have a couple of questions about
this that we've gotten please continue
to use tool and email if you are using
them and if you aren't using them please
begin using them they do not affect your
key in any way they're completely
separate from the key however they help
us help you by identifying the software
package all right that it's attached to
these requests and a number of you have
expressed interest in having distributed
keys so that one software package may
have multiple keys so the key itself
isn't going to identify the software
package for us tool does so if you need
us to help you understand activity for
your piece of software and how it's been
distributed and what we're seeing then
tool is required all right for us to be
able to give you that kind of
information email is the contact
information for you the developer right
so that we can contact you about that
kind of information it should not be a
customer contact it should be a
developer contact so that we can talk
directly to evers monitoring and and
designing that code base all right so
that we can help you deliver quality
services to your users all right so
that's basically what I want to say
today I just want to encourage you to
stay tuned on our on our social media
you know there's the learn page if we if
we do give more webinars and we don't
have any plan right now but if we do
need to give additional ones will
publicize them they're also on the
social media and again here's the link I
was promising for updates on utilities
please subscribe to utilities announced
and you get the slides you can just
click there and go to the link I've also
just put the link there it's the mailman
list and Phil utilities announce mailing
list you're not going to get spammed and
only one sort
twice a month or so you'll get updates
about the e-utilities but they're
important updates so we try and respect
your time and your inbox but we when we
think it's important we're gonna send
things there if you have questions
please write to info at NCBI and also
I'll invite you to ask us about the
possibility of negotiating higher rate
keys than 10 so as we've talked about in
previous webinars if you think that you
will need a higher rate than 10 per
second we can talk with you about
adjusting that upward and so if you'd
like to engage us in such a conversation
we'd be happy to do that
just write to info and we can follow up
with you about that right so that's what
I have to say today I'm going to turn it
over to Peter to see what questions we
have thanks Eric there are a number of
questions and here's some of them I
addressed but some of them I don't
actually know the answers to and so I'm
gonna let you take a shot at them
there's a question the first question we
got actually is about this question of a
reset time and they're talking about a
particular thing called the ex rate
limit reset time indicating when the
current window ends I mean the window is
one second so I don't quite know that I
understand the question do you want to
address that yeah I'm not sure that I
would understand the full context there
I would I would say if you if you want
to talk to us more about that just write
write info and we'll talk to you more
about that what I can say is that the
way that we're again determining the
rates just based on the moving one
second window so we monitor the key or
the IP address and if we see incoming
requests that in a given one second
window they exceed the right limit so if
your rate is three and we see more than
three requests starts all right you know
one second window then you'll get an
error right until that rate in a moving
one second window drops below three so
that's basically what I can say and if
you have other questions about that you
know please write and we can follow up
okay couple of questions it's you
address them in the talk but I thought
it would be worth you know pointing out
again somebody did ask about the email
and tool parameter and I think as you
pointed out now
required but very important that you
include that so that we can get in touch
with you another one was the response
rates we are given in the headers and I
think he discovered that they actually
are given in the headers yes thank you
for putting that out I should have
mentioned that honestly you should be
expecting the status 429 so any error
you get well should give you a 429 at
least that's what we certainly have
found in our own tests and other people
reported that to us so we're pretty
confident that people are seeing those
and it's a little snippet in the header
correct so you should be able to just
look for a 429 yes and the rate is in
that error message so the the integer
that you'll see at the end of that
little data blob that you get back is
the rate that we observed so when I on
the slide it was 11 I believe which is
like 1 over 10 so that's what your
observed okay another good question is
about many of the different you know
pearl modules that are available there's
one that he cites by OE utilities by Oh
DB utilities and he says it hasn't been
updated to support the API keys and he
wants to know if we have reached out to
the developers and I don't think we have
yeah thanks for the question it's a it's
a good point I don't know that we have
specifically reached out to
organizations like biopython bioperl
and other kinds of organizations like
that we often are in contact with them
in any case it's it's a question
honestly you know for them in terms of
what they like to support it's certainly
you know one approach that they could do
is to have more support for keys in
there they may choose to do that they
may choose to have you know developers
solve that problem on their own I don't
have any direct information from them
but thank you for that I mean it's
certainly possible we can get in contact
with them and get some clarity okay
another question is somebody asked can I
make sure no key will be used for
distributed service I mean I think the
answer to that is we can't make sure
that no key will be used that way but
that's not what we intend that every
user every distributed service should
have their own key so this is a this is
a fairly common class of questions in
that
a number of software developers
obviously will distribute their their
codebase and basically if you are
distributing software in that way it's
good to have a key right for the
individual customers if you think that
the use cases that the customers have
will drive their use over three requests
per second it really is dependent upon
the nature of your software and the
number of requests that you tend to fire
all right then a typical customer would
tend to fire so it's a judgment call on
your part if you if you're concerned
about this and would like to talk with
us about strategies that that is a lot
of the kind of conversations that we've
been having with a number of software
vendors we're happy to engage in those
so what are the things that you could
think about is perhaps having a default
key that would cover most of your
customers and we could set a rate all
right that would cover most cases you
may have some customers that are very
heavy users and you know that we may be
able to give them particular keys so
these are the kinds of things that we
can talk about it really just depends a
lot on the nature of your software how
you distribute it and the manner in
which you access the utility API like
how many requests are you actually
making there are ways that we can talk
to you that might actually help you
reduce the number of requests that you
need to make so that's why having these
conversations is important to try and
explore your use cases and what would be
helpful for your customers so here's a
somewhat philosophical perhaps question
the API key is only there to help in CBI
monitor the number of requests per
second right it's on our personal side
to adapt develop scripts which will
handle this ten requests per second
limitation we wanted to sort of talk
about why we're doing this so there's a
number of topics there that we could
talk about one topic is like why do you
want to do the keys at all and it comes
back to kind of a general part of our
mission as the National Library of
Medicine and providing free services to
the public and so free does not mean
unregulated meaning that we have had
many cases in the past where
particular a a small number of users
will essentially create a denial of
service attack on our servers because of
heavy use and our mission is to provide
these services to the public and so we
have to do everything we can to make
sure that the public has access 24/7 and
so that basically means preventing
excessively high use for any of our
services whether that's web FTP API
whatever it might be and so the keys
help us do that the keys also help you
and I understand that from some
perspectives it might be hard to see
that but the keys help you because it
helps us make the services more reliable
because they're less vulnerable to these
kinds of attacks and once the attacks
happen you won't be able to get to us
and if you have processes that are
automated and your customers depend on
those processes we want them to be up
for you and preventing these kinds of
spikes and problematic activity allows
us to have a services up more often than
not it also allows us to inform you as
developers about what's happening with
your software and to alert you earlier
to problems that we're seeing so if
people are abusing your software or are
you are providing you know sets of
requests to us that are harmful to our
ability to provide services to the
public then it helps us help you
understand what's happening and correct
those issues so at the moment the way
that we're rolling keys out yes as you
as you point out it kind of is on you to
think about what your rates are and as
we explore this further there may be
other ways that we can you know modify
and extend and perhaps strengthen the
way that the keys work and make them
more flexible and we're certainly
interested in input from the community
about how that will happen and we've had
some discussions about that or already
so you know we're very open to having
your thoughts and suggestions about ways
in which you know the services can be
more adaptable to your needs but this is
where we are currently ok another there
there's several more questions that I
don't think we're going to have time to
get to all of them
if we don't we'll answer them in the Q&A
document so I'll put that up on the FTP
site and you can take a look just a
couple of more one is this question
about being blocked if if we continue to
exceed the Ray will we be blocked and I
think the answer to that is no because
that's one of the points of this is you
can't do you know we're throttling you
so you can't actually do damage but I'll
what Erik address that it's an important
question for those of you who are
experienced users of the API who may
have been blocked in the past so we do
have a policy by which we will block
access to an IP or a set of IPs if we
observe extraordinarily high rates of
activity and the the manifestation of
such a block is to have no ability to
reach our servers and on the web you'll
see kind of a black screen that clearly
indicates that you've been prevented
access with instructions for how to
proceed to restore access the API keys
have nothing to do with that process at
all so the API keys are actually a way
to help us prevent that because we don't
want to be doing that we want people to
have access so what happens with the
keys as Peter was indicating and as I
tried to indicate is an instantaneous
and very temporary cessation of service
for a particular IP or API key that's
giving us a high number of requests so
again the the manifestation of the rate
being exceeded because I don't want to
use the term block because you aren't
it's simply that those individual
requests will receive an error message
until the rate drops below the threshold
and so you'll just see gaps and data
returns or data returns that are you
know really unusually small because all
they reach all they'll receive is the
error message so that's what you'll see
as a user or if you're a web user or a
user of an app a third party app develop
on top of the API you simply won't be
getting data back all right for that
period when the rates are high so we
don't memorize that there
there's no recording of that activity is
just the you'll get an error until the
rates go down again so there is no
blocking happening there is no permanent
memory of any of that it's just an
instantaneous response okay that's
that's all we have time for right now
and as I said if there are additional
questions that we didn't really address
and any the questions that we did
address in fact we're gonna put them in
that document so I like to thank
everybody for coming and thanks Eric for
presenting this and we'll see you next
time